- Before the break, we were
talking about the Carter's
Show Her Love Baby
Shower I recently hosted.
There were 100 new mamas and mamas-to-be
in the virtual celebration.
It was so awesome,
and we actually have a few
of them joining us right now.
Morgan, Amanda, Mary, are you there?
Hello, everybody!
How are y'all doing?
Congratulations to all of you.
- Thank you.
- So exciting!
Okay, so Morgan, you just
had baby Beckham, right?
So was it a difficult path
to bring him into this world?
I heard it was.
- It was.
So I was told at 13 years
old that I had endometriosis
and that I would never have children.
So by the time I met my husband,
it was like a deal-breaker for
most people that I had dated,
so I told him pretty early on like,
"Hey, just so you know,
I can't have kids."
Just as casual as that, too,
and he's like, "No problem.
We'll cross that bridge
when we get to it."
And literally a week
later it was Mother's Day.
I went into urgent care
because I had this migraine
I couldn't get rid of, and
I found out I was pregnant.
So (laughs) yeah, it was
kind of a funny story.
But we were not expecting
that news at all,
and then between that and
six and a half years later,
we have had many pregnancies
that have resulted in loss
through miscarriage and ectopic,
so we tried for a really long time
to bring another baby into this world,
and like nothing went right.
So I was like, I'm gonna go
ahead and get my mom makeover
and find some other things to focus on.
And two months later,
I found out I was pregnant with Beckham.
So yeah, things happen
when they're supposed to,
but (laughs) it's been a...
- That's crazy!
One of my friends was actually,
the same thing happened
to her when she was young,
and they said because
of the endometriosis,
she wouldn't be able to have children.
And she tried for years, and finally,
they were able to make it happen.
She ended up having twins and it was...
That's a hard thing to hear
if your dream is to have kids,
you know?
And that happens to a lot of women,
so thank you, first of
all, for being so open
and vulnerable about that story,
'cause a lot of people
connect to that story.
Amanda, your pregnancy also came
as a bit of shock, right?
- Yeah.
Actually I'm 37,
so I wasn't even sure
if it was still possible
to get pregnant or if it
was gonna be difficult,
but I went off birth control in early 2019
and we kinda just figured
whatever happens, happens.
Fast forward a year and a little bit,
and we found out at the end
of March that I'm pregnant.
So that was, you know, a great news
and very exciting, especially
during the times of COVID.
But it's made it a little
difficult, too, COVID,
you know, again, it's my first pregnancy,
so I'm not really sure what
to expect with the doctors,
and my husband hasn't been able
to come to any of my appointments.
So that's been kind of difficult.
He's been wanting to hear the heartbeat
and see the ultrasounds,
and all that fun stuff,
so I've been trying to FaceTime with him
as much as possible,
but we went for our 12 week appointment,
well, I went for my 12 week appointment,
and I was FaceTiming him and my parents,
and just so they could hear the heartbeat,
when the surprise, you know,
big surprise from the tech
was, "Oh my God, it's twins."
We didn't know that it was twins,
we weren't planning for twins,
it was really exciting to watch, you know,
both my parents and my
husband just kinda overcome
with emotion in that moment.
- Congratulations, by the way.
Like what a gift.
And like to not know if it
was gonna happen or not,
and then you get two little gifts,
which is awesome.
- I know.
- It was great.
You know, you pray for a miracle
and then you get two, so.
- You get two for one!
That's amazing!
I've had two pregnancies, so
I slightly hate you. (laughs)
But no, congratulations, Amanda.
That's a really, really cool story.
Mary, you've had an
interesting experience as well.
You're a nurse in an ICU.
So what's it like to
be an essential worker
who's pregnant, during a pregnancy?
Did you have concerns, obviously?
- Definitely kind of
unnerving time to be pregnant.
Definitely unnerving time for everyone,
but you know, my husband and I both...
He works, he's a corrections
officer in a jail
and I'm in a hospital,
so we're both kind of in a high-risk area.
So you know, just kind
of day in and day out,
things changing.
My husband and I, this
is our third pregnancy,
first child, so you know,
we were kind of very scared
going into things.
Thinking, well, we've had
two unsuccessful pregnancies
and now we have one and now
we're kind of dealing with
this virus that nobody
knows anything about,
and you know, I'm working in
the ICU directly with patients
who have been exposed and have the virus,
so it's been kind of, kinda scary.
But you know, we have
a healthy little girl,
and that's three, or three
weeks away from her due date,
so it's very exciting, and you
know, things have been good
and she's been healthy this
whole process, so it's exciting.
I'm glad to be near the
finish line. (laughs)
- Oh, oh, my gosh.
I remember the finish line.
The finish line is so beautiful.
(Mary laughs)
It's like, oh, finally.
I love you, get out, get
out, get out. (laughs)
That's really great.
Hey, and thank you so much,
first of all, from all of us
for what you do, especially
during this time,
putting your life on the line.
Not only yours, but your little baby's.
Like that's...
- Tough.
That's, it's above and beyond
to ask someone to do that,
so thank you so much from all of us
to just you and all the
essential workers out there.
That's really, really...
- [Mary] Thank you, yeah.
- Courageous of you.
They already got to have an enormous
virtual baby shower before,
Huggies gifted you a year of
diapers at the Carter's Shower,
and they hope you'll fall
in love with the Huggies
special delivery diapers and wipes,
which are the perfect pair
for your perfect care.
But they wanna do more.
So they're starting a $5,000 college fund
for the baby of whomever wins
the game we're about to play.
Are you ready?
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- I mean, everybody could
use money towards college.
It is so expensive.
All right, let's play Baby Boom or Bust.
(upbeat music)
Okay, so this is simple.
I'm gonna ask you
questions all about babies.
You each have cards and pens
right there in front of you, right?
You ready?
Okay, and when I ask the question,
you write your answer down.
Then we'll see who gets it right.
You get it right, you get a point.
Let's do this, all right?
All right, first question.
What's the first sense a baby develops?
(timer ticking)
Okay, are we all ready?
Okay, show me.
Okay, no one wins this one!
'Cause you're all wrong! (laughs)
The answer is actually touch.
I didn't know that as well, so
we're all failures together.
Okay, so let's, (laughs)
it's only a failure if
you don't keep trying.
Let's keep trying.
Okay, here we go.
Which celebrity named their baby Stormi?
(timer ticking)
All right, ladies, so
let's see the answers
you came up with.
Let's see what you wrote.
Oh my God!
Okay, I didn't know that at all,
and all of you got that right.
Kylie Jenner is the answer.
Way to go, you all get points, okay.
I'm the loser there.
Okay, so here's the next one.
What percentage of women
actually give birth
on their due date?
So here's the thing, this is hard.
That's like a one out of 100,
so I'm just gonna say whoever
gets the closest to, you know,
the percentage of women
actually give birth
on their due date, whoever gets
the closest gets the point.
Are y'all cool with that?
Okay, okay.
- Sure.
Here we go, show me your answer.
Oh my gosh!
One of you got the answer!
I had no idea, no one...
Okay, I cannot even believe
you right now, Mary.
You got that right.
5%! All right, so we have another one.
Babies are born without which body part?
Write down your answers.
(timer ticking)
I think I actually did know this one,
'cause I thought it was weird.
- [Amanda] Yes.
- Okay, y'all ready?
Okay, everybody show.
Certain types of bones, kneecap,
kneecaps for the win!
Amanda and Morgan get it.
Oh my gosh, it's a three way tie!
Well, it seems like all
we can do here folks
is just give you all $5,000
for your babies for college.
That's what we're gonna do! (laughs)
- That's so awesome!
- That is so awesome!
- Thank you!
I can't believe it was
- Thank you.
a three way!
I love that, everyone wins!
That was so cool!
But literally, I'm so glad that all of you
ended up getting that.
That's courtesy of Huggies.
Thank you so much, Huggies.
That money is gonna go to good use.
And again, congratulations not
only on the five grand y'all,
but just on your little ones.
These are, they're miracle stories too,
you know, happening.
So it's a beautiful
thing to hear that hope.
And I know a lot of mamas
out there who struggle
getting pregnant and
everything coming to fruition.
That's a hard, hard thing
to deal with emotionally
and physically, mentally.
So thank you for being open,
thank you for being vulnerable
with your stories and congratulations,
and I just can't wait for y'all to all...
I know Beckham's born,
but the others aren't,
so I can't wait for y'all
to snuggle and smell 'em,
they're so cute.
All right, y'all have a good one.
Stay safe and healthy, all right?
- [Guests] Thank you!
- All right, bye ladies!
All right, it's time for a break.
We'll be right back with What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)